in the shadow of Kenya second highest
peak Mount Kenya the old pajetta
Conservancy is a very special Nature
Reserve not only because of its abundant
wildlife and stunning landscapes but
also because with three northern white
rhinos being the last of their kind they
bear the burden of ensuring the survival
of the breed to create the optimum
reproductive conditions all the Jezza
left nothing to chance yet there's
little help number of mating recorded
unfortunately none has translated into a
pregnancy so we then decided by the best
thing would be to bring in a a sultan
white bull and expose that to one of the
not on white rhino phenols southern
white rhinos are closely related to the
northern White's but the efforts to save
northern White's by crossbreeding failed
biologists have found out that the two
remaining females are not capable of
reproducing with the male also incapable
of breeding their extinction seems to be
a matter of only a few years only fifty
years ago the northern white rhinoceros
roamed throughout Uganda South Sudan and
the Central African Republic but growing
rhino horn demand in China and Vietnam
weights used in traditional medicine led
to a Belgian epidemic by 1990 just 25
northern white rhinos were left for
warden Muhammad duo the breeds impending
extinction is nearer to his heart than
for many of his colleagues at or pajetta
I don't do this for money
I've loved animals since my school days
I've not done any other work apart from
dealing with rhinos that is what makes
me happy I love them because they are
just animals they are harmless
they don't even talk yet they are
mistreated and hunted down by poachers
come on the father of three boys says
his relationship to the gentle patch
Adams is a very emotional one Muir is
what dog Opia
I've raised the often rhinos whose
mothers have been killed by poachers
we've spent the night with them in the
bush I'll spend the night beside her
here to blanket and had two of my own
when she was hungry she'd push me with
her aunt wake me up like the way I shall
so except father when she wants to pee
so I take these rhinos like my own
children biologists say northern White's
may well be extinct in the next 10 years
so scientists and I'll turn into
high-tech reproductive techniques they
might be the last chance to save them an
amazing technique we just need to be
careful that we have looked at all the
risks involved and therefore we can get
a signal on when we can start doing that
the method involves creating northern
white rhino embryos which could be just
stated by southern white rhino females
but even if the program is successful it
would take decades for the breed to
bounce back until then the last three of
their kind will have to remain on the
armed protection